الخلاف السياسي والدبلوماسي بين المانيا
وبولندا الذي تعود جذوره لعقود يتكرر من
جديد لكن هذه المره زاد من حدته العرض
الالماني بتركيب بطاريه باتريوت شرقي
بولندا والذي جاء بالتزامل مع مقتل
مواطنين من الصواريخ التي سقطت في قريه
بولنديه بالقرب من الحدود الاوكرانيه
صحيفه نيويورك
على ان منظومه باتريوت المضاده للصواريخ
اثارت ازمه سياسيه ليس فقط على مستوى
البلدين فحسب بل وصل الامر الى داخل
الناتو الذي تعهد مرارا وتكرارا بتعزيز
دفاعات حلفائه الجويه وهو الامر الذي قبض
التماسك والتضامن بين المانيا وبولندا من
جهه وحل في شمال الاطلسي من جهه اخرى
الحكومه البولنديه قبلت العرض الذي طرحته
برلين قبل اسبوعين بنصب بطاريه صواريخ
باتريوت وذلك بسبب الضغوط الدوليه التي
تعرضت لها وانتقاد المواطنين البولنديين
لقرار رفض العرض الالماني
بعدما رفضت هذا العرض واقترحت على نظيرتها
الالمانيه ارسالها هذه المنظومه الدفاعيه
الى جارتها في كييف
استطاعات الراي التي كشفت عنها صحيفه تظهر
ان نسبه كبيره من البولنديين يعتقدون ان
وجود صواريخ المانيه في بولندا فكره جيده
برلين رفضت بدورها الاقتراح البولندي
وبررت رفضها بان قرار ارسال الصواريخ الى
اوكرانيا يتطلب اجراءات فنيه ولوجسيه
معقده تبدا بموافقه اغلب الاعضاء في الحلم
وتنتهي بنشر الجنود الالمان في اوكرانيا
لتشغيل البطاريات وهو الامر الذي قد يشعر
فتيل المواجهه المباشره مع روسيا سلطان
العربيه